yeah it was real man [__] the 90s were
real that's what I want to say [__] that
was real so you got shout out at 14.
your brother got shot at by your own his
own [__] homie that when they grew up
yeah he got shot when I was probably
about 15 I believe and then after that
get shot in the ass right uh no he got
shot in the foot and he was running no
actually he was running to the car to
break a bottle over the dude's you know
face and before he even got to the car
dude pulled out uh you know 25 and
instead of shooting at him no he did
shoot down you know what I mean but it's
still ricocheted hit him up oh could you
imagine so when he turned around and he
picked that foot up it went right in his
foot I mean I'm talking right on that
the stepping toe like on the foot you
ever step on a Lego
[Laughter]
you [__] you ever step on a Lego
here's a 25.
your dad
[Applause]